charlotte aubin vous incarner le
personnage de jacques francoeur dans
l'échappée c'est un euro qui vous colle
à la peau et qui vous suit depuis six
ans déjà je pense que ça ça comble
marchands de votre carrière son rôle
mais oui vraiment venait tout juste de
sortir de l'école quand j'ai décroché ce
rôle là puis c'est drôle de grandir avec
un personnage aussi été je me vois comme
interprète aussi qui prend du galon qui
s'améliore ou qui se définit plus de
voir un personnage évoluer avec moi je
trouve ça vraiment formidables en fait
et je m'ajoute quand vous aurez dans la
rue pour vous en parle et oui vraiment
plus avait il ya comme une espèce de
saga autour d'une siècle en ce moment
dans l'émission les gens sont inquiets
pour moi la personne
n'existe pas touchés comme je pense que
les gens font la différence entre la
fiction et la réalité mais ce personnage
auquel on s'attache aussi tissé comme la
candeur la générosité la douceur fait
les gens ils veulent pas qu'ils arrivent
du mal à ce personnage là donc on va ce
que j'ai fait dans nos archives et j'ai
trouvé des images du tapis rouge de
roméo et juliette oh my god
samy 15 ans oui la météo numéro 4
souvenez vous gardé de cette époque là
parce que tout a commencé votre wii est
heureusement mais en fait c'est très
candide en fait à ce moment là j'étais
très très très candide je me suis
inscrite à des auditions publiques juste
parce que j'aimais le théâtre ça
m'intéressait le cinéma puis je me
rendais pas compte du gros processus de
la grosse machine mêmes qui étaient
autour de ce film là c'est une
expérience formidable j'ai rencontré des
gens avec qui j'ai encore à me
aujourd'hui dampierre mignaux le
directeur photo ça a été une grande
rencontre avec jeanne moreau toujours
très très grande rencontre qui m'a
beaucoup appris sur le jeu qui m'a
appris aussi comment être une femme dans
ce métier là ouais je trouve qu'elle
comment être une femme dans ce métier je
trouve que c est la lavette de
l'élégance piste du chien je pense que
c'est les choses que j'essaie d'avoir
moi aussi une espèce de goût du travail
a un goût de la rencontre avec beaucoup
de caractère mais aussi beaucoup de
malléabilité le délicatesse des croûtes
de l'aude accueille oui parce que j'ai
gardées cela d'elle et de bien des
rencontres que j'ai faites par la suite
mais c'était comme une bonne menteur
pour commencer mais ton bon donc à
compans charlotte aubin élégance et si
ce soir j'aimerais ça que le monde des
affaires oui oui ok mais comme une
espèce d'intensité mais habillée de
délicatesse maintenant c'est ce que je
vise tout jeune vous rêviez de devenir
comédienne mais vous étiez aussi
musicien parce que de larges de 4 à 16
ans vous jouiez du violon ouais en quoi
le jeu et la musique se complètent pour
vous mais je pense que ça donne
nécessairement une rigueur l'hautil je
pense de 4 à 16 ans il fallait que je
pratique au moins une heure par jour
parce que ça donne une méthode de
travail puis je trouve que dans la
musique puis d'en rendre intègre dans
l'interprétation et comme vous se mettre
dans le point de vue de l'auteur ou du
compositeur je pense qu'il y avait ceux
pour le violon fallait se mettre un peu
dans dans l'esprit dans l'époque je
pense que c'est un refus aussi au
théâtre ou au cinéma fo comme embrasser
la vision de l'auteur du réalisateur
quand je pense que toutes ses connexes
au bout du compte je sais pas si je leur
ressemble j'ai montré que ça fait
peut-être partie de quelque chose qui
est intrinsèque tout instant justement
votre discipline a été mise à l'épreuve
dans la série virage où vous incarnez
frédéric inspiré du parcours de marianne
st-gelais sase est une préparation
monstre pour enfiler les patins et
façonnage parce que vous êtes entraînés
pendant sept huit mois ouais une espèce
de six mois ça a été vraiment très
intense mais j'étais seulement lada je
faisais rien d'autre pendant six mois je
n'ai que penser à sur le bâti mon corps
pour ce rôle le jeu quand c'est arrivé
la première journée sur le plateau je me
sentais bien je me sentais prête parce
que j'avais travaillé beaucoup en amont
moi j'ai vraiment comme des couvertures
mais mon corps pouvait être un atout
pouvait se transformer moi j'accepte de
prendre du poids autant que d'en perdre
de devenir musclé comme de devenir tout
petit je pense que les quelque chose
d'en être interprète où on est un peu un
peu fou là on a envie de vraiment de
d'être l'autre de devenir l'autre avec
ce personnage là j'ai vraiment pu faire
jusqu'au bout ce à quoi on voudrait que
je suis fière de moi c'est peut-être pub
en terre désolée mais je suis fier de
cette préparation de femmes de cinéma
cinémas indépendants oui vous êtes
justement la porte-parole du festival
regards witz val du court métrage de
saguenay j'imagine que ça c'est un beau
cadeau pour vous en 2008 à whiston
honneur je suis vraiment très très
contente que j'ai fait beaucoup de
courts métrages c'est comme super
important pour moi dans mon parcours et
gens consomment beaucoup puis ce
festival c'est mythique qui en fait une
place au court métrage au québec qui est
formidable j'ai jamais pu y aller j'ai
tout le temps été pris à montréal pour
le travail ou quoi que ce soit que ça va
être ma première fois la botte qui
emplissent porte parole c'est bien
excitant cette entrevue a lieu dans un
local de répétition du théâtre la
licorne à montréal où vous devez jouer
patate dans les prochaines semaines oui
oui la nouvelle adaptation du film deux
femmes en or mais version catherine
l'égérie question d'émancipation de la
femme j'imagine que vous avez entre à
huy c'est la deuxième fois que ces
reporters en plus on a tellement envie
de jouer ce spectacle il est prêt c'est
intelligent c'est drôle c'est des
partenaires de jeu formidable que l'on
croise les doigts ce serait vraiment le
fun que ça se passe je trouve que ce que
ça dit sur la sexualité la monogamie
l'émancipation féminine on a besoin
d'entendre ce genre de texte le fait que
en espérant que ça se passe charlotte
aubin merci beaucoup s'est fait un
plaisir